[Musik]
die wohl wichtigste kunstschau ist die
dokumente normalerweise in kassel
beheimatet und dort im deutschen
durchschnitt ort findet die kunst ihren
raum beobachten wir seit boys doch
dieses mal ist alles anders
kurator adam schicker die documenta
kurzem zweigeteilt und unter dem titel
von athen lernen gestellt ja auch bei
den griechen auf dem hof der krise die
kunst um so opulenten das früchte trägt
das hat mir selbst herausfinden eine
skulptur mit bester aussicht auf partie
[Musik]
aus marmor gemeißelt mahnte es an die
flüchtlingskrise in griechenland ein
zelt auf dem hügel von fifa boss
mit blick auf die wiege der europäischen
zivilisation akropolis das lernt man von
at&s ist über bild und gleichzeitig
größte katastrophe von europa
[Musik]
athen vor einem jahr
die flüchtlings- und wirtschaftskrise
nicht auf ihrem höhepunkt ausgeblutet
vom staat protestiert die menge auf dem
syntagma-platz gegen noch mehr abgaben
der platz ist längst zum symbol des
griechischen widerstands geworden und
heute auf dem selben platz wird gemäss
in andere performance der dokumentarfilm
10 werden alte waren säcke zu einem
großen teppich zusammengeflickt was
lernt die cool star vom widerstand in
zusammenhang
die griechische schriftstellerin am
andern hollo bollo ist skeptisch
auskunft an schauplatz der krise soll
auf der einen seite finde ich es sehr
gut wenn eine große institution wie die
dokumente nach kriegen land kommt und
sich interessiert was ihr passiert auf
der anderen seite könnte es zur
explosion der tiefe für ihn eine art
fiesen tourismus erschaffen aktive eine
neue schlagseite geben sie sozusagen
verkaufen
die krise als attraktion für die kunst
der documenta leiter adam niemczyk
vereint wir haben gelernt vorgefertigte
konzepte aufzugeben und mit ihnen einige
unserer hoffnung
wir sind eingetaucht in die dunkelheit
des nichtwissens einstelle alles schon
zu kennen bevor er beginnt
[Musik]
so fährt man durch eine
krisengeschüttelte stadt auf der suche
nach der kunst und entdeckt ein museum
für zeitgenössische kunst das nur dank
der gelder der dokumente eröffnen konnte
am eingang der vorschlag doch mit oliven
die schulden griechenlands zu begleichen
ein weg über den dächern von athen zeigt
dass man das dach über dem kopf längst
verloren hat
[Musik]
und auch aus abfall lässt sich kunst
produzieren
der künstler daniel knorr nutzt
überreste von athen straßen um bücher zu
produzieren aus dem nichts etwas
erschaffen das lernt man von
griechenland es ist eine art über die
ökonomie nachzudenken
und was ist bedeutet zu verschulden zu
haben dahinter steckt ein system der
macht
es sind nicht einfach nur zahlen
es ist ein system das einem auferlegt
wurde
aber es gibt beispiele von anderen
systemen die solche exzesse verhindert
eines der beispiele an der documenta
sind die masken des indigenen künstlers
budick kanadische urvölker verschenken
sie besiegt gibt es keinen eine utopie
für griechenland die dokumente holt viel
geschichte hervor um mit historischen
bildern die aktuellen krisen zu
betrachten
[Musik]
und durchstreift man die stadt entdeckt
man an den abgelegensten orten kunst die
politisch aufgeladen ist wie die
reifenproduktion der nigerianischen
künstlerin autobomben kranker weiße aus
öl und kohle hergestellt
nicola erinnert an verbrannte erde und
bei verbrannter erde denken wir an den
krieg in syrien
die leute mussten deswegen fürchten
vorher gab es sauerstoff zum leben im
moment wo man zu ersticken droht ihnen
die leute weg zu gehen sauber werden mit
blick auf den krieg von athen lernen
heißt von allen krisen lernen
doch es gibt sie die griechischen pläne
auf weiteres griechische künstlerin
alexandra bachtler selbst dem risiko ein
denkmal
diese musik kultur entstand aus einer
flüchtlingskrise der zwanziger jahre
[Musik]
ist keins verfügung
terry
und kein schmerz über den verlust der
heimat extrem sind um eine art
beschrieben den zustand gegenüber vom
eigenen vater und liebe da seine eigene
form aufrecht gehalten oder ob man die
nato fresse halten eine musik für den
verlust gelingt uns doch die fassade war
[Musik]
unfair institutionen das alles natürlich
ein versäumnis um vorne dran alles noch
mit roten sesseln und gold im mund ist
und das hat ganz viel in so funktioniert
das ist keine fassade und das findet
trotzdem statt
die kunst land von athen dass die krise
erfinderisch macht das die perspektiven
zwar nicht gut sind man sich aber eine
kultur des überlebens sichert symbol
dafür ist die akropolis seit
jahrtausenden in der stadt rund
[Musik]